or just disappointed
cuz that's how I'm feeling right now
Today we're reviewing
"r/foundfelix"
I didn't think this was real and I didn't think it was what
I thought it was or at least I didn't
think it was what I thought it was but
it's a subreddit dedicated to finding
Felix.
That's right everybody we did it
we hit peak reddit everyone I'm so
confused
Why did I find Felix on this Swedish
dating site?
Date Swedish man
Hey, 'kärlek finns inte gör'
Love does not e-wait the translation of that is: love doesn't exist
will date Swedish man trust in massage
would you like some trust in massage
Found him in a Dutch sucker Club
Stop! this whole subreddit is racist
god fucking damn it.
Why does everyone look like me? And why has it taken us this
long to discover that? Found him. What the heck is this? You have not found me
you will never find me because I never leave my house because I don't have legs
literally this entire sub oh that's my colour scheme pewds, not pewds
I get it now. Found him in New York that
actually looks like me what the hell
How does this keep happening what is going on guys what the heck is going on bruh
I demand an answer our aliens real. PewdDiePie has changed so much over the years
why does everyone keep looking like me
smh I'm legit getting freaked out
we have Christian PewDiePie we have virgin PewDiePie
we have airport PD pie we have that
actually genuinely looks like PewDiePie
PewDiePie we have football PewDiePie and we have another that actually goddamn
looks like PewDiePie PewDiePie why are
there so many facking PewDiePies this ends
now I'm done with it where do you find
these pictures as well this dude just
straight-up met Pewds why does that beep I have my dog?
Pewds put 5 feet high I will not stand for this cyberbullying
I am so confused okay this is getting
creepy guys I found PewDiePie from years ago
alter reality PewDiePie multiverse
number 55 PewDiePie. Y'all know it's
fake because he has legs. Oh okay oof thank
god at least we have some method to figuring
out which is the real PewDiePie
I met the Pewds look-alike too.
Same place as the other guy oh God and even he
looks alike like the other one that
The conspiracy. Rare photo of Pewds during world war. Indian PewDiePie.
Found Pewds tagged section hey look it's High School virgin PewDiePie
Great, um Felix is that you I
don't know it could be might as well
when you watch the news and you find
another Felix look-alike that's
hilarious pardon me it seems like I am quite
quenched for thirst is that how you say
it
time for sponsor G Fuel sponza.
you may have seen me sip on these bad boys
for quiet a while and you may be
wondering what is he actually drinking
there is that part of some conspiracy?
No it's not okay this is genuinely great
sponsor G fuel everybody. I used to be
skeptical to G fuel but then Brad
recommended it to me and as soon as I
tried it I was sold on it okay I don't
know by you guys but I used to drink
energy drinks and I tested out G fuel I
like genuinely I was sceptic to it but I
find it to be a healthier solution to
just drink and G fuel instead it also
doesn't make me I mean I don't know if
this is true or not but generally my
experience when you're drinking when I
drink an energy drink I get hyped for
like 10 minutes and then it goes away
but with G fuel I generally don't feel
that I just feel like I get more energy
and it boosts me throughout the day Wow
epic and there's so many goddamn
delicious flavors it's funny every
person that I recommended G fuel to me
has also being skeptic they're like I
don't know and then they try it I'm like
oh that's great I just bought 50. Some of my favorite is
golden apple pear this thing is
beautiful green apple is also amazing
sour chug rug incredible flavor I mean I
hate to say it but getting keemstar
cotton candy it's pretty good rainbow
sherbet incredible kiwi strawberry mmm
if you check out the link in the
description you can get my top flavors
that's right everybody but wait enter
the code pewdiepie and you get not 10% off
not 15% off, not 20% off 30%!! off baby
add the code PewDiePie in your checkout and try it out see if you like it this offer
I found Felix back in 2013 I'm so sick
of this I don't know what my reaction to
this is that's the problem I don't know
if I'm annoyed I don't know if I'm
scared and I don't know if I'm should be
laughing or a crying. Time traveler Felix
Goddammit. Why are there so many facking Felix
These people didn't exist until this subreddit existed
goddammit Kazoo kid
Parallel universe Felix closer to the
What is that? old universe transgender Felix great oh my god why are they so many world war
Felix goddamnit that actually looks like
me I'm Franz now I am a Franz now you
know this is just going to get worse
y'all look how many Felix i found
congratulations good job just found
Felix in India oh my god that's t-series
vs. PewDiePie and I'm not even there I
just realized I could just get all of
these speedy PewDiePies and make them take over my channel and then I don't have to
be here anymore that's great oh my god
it's racecar PewDiePie racecar fan
PewDiePie everybody hey look it's way better beard PewDiePie
incredible Felix fighting a black guy
I would never by the way for the record
Vox media I would never That would never enter my hemisphere of thought to ever
do that because I would actually die
Jesus Christ
Is that racist?
Is that how you tell if it's me or not if there's
many PewDiePie then that means I can
shift blame on all my controversies to
other PewDiePie I have never done
anything bad in my entire life
this has all been old reality PewDiePie the conspiracy is that news media
created fake PewDiePies to frame me InnoCentPie
That's right that's who I am
Didn'tDoAnythingPie. What a fuck oh my
god Jesus Christ oh my god how many more
can there be it's looking under chair
PewDiePie weAHhAweHye
Van Gogh PewDiePie
Why does it's not stop make it stop
omnipresent bean it's Felix time
traveler party wig PewDiePie I'm crying
I'm actually crying. Virgin outside in the snow
PewDiePie this is where it all started
okay to understand how this happened we
need to understand how it started it
started off with this goddamn I mean
God Lord
Great Lord Christian PewDiePie.
Oh my god it's Felix blonde hair and beard
Oh my god
this proves everything there's again
traitor PewDiePie, "PewDiePie delivers cake to
T-Series high quality in India *REAL*"
TraDiePie he's a traitor stop him
I will not stand for this which I can't by
the way no legs can help it. How the F
does this keep happening. What if all
these clones say the N-word and kill
Pewds reputation oh my god this is it
this is what I've been saying I never
made any Jew jokes I never said any bad words
and I always asked myself How did
this keep happening?
I am 100% innocent
Oh it's me PewDiePie from one day ago
How many PewDiePie's are there I have returned
because I have found the source it all
started with a post from dankmemes
white people all Asian looked the same
also white people this is what I'm
talking about I have found the source of
this problem and it is once again
racism every day another Felix is
appearing who the heck is this guy
filosophy lecture Felix. That even looks
exactly like me. Bros what am i doing
on a train bros. All these poor PewDiePie
look-alikes everyone's snapping a photo
of them going like [giggling] This looks just like Pew-
PewDiePie into the PewDieVerse
Let's not go there
met PewDiePie at the victory
grill the other day great guy
wow what a great guy oh my god it's
PewDiePie in FallOut 4
It's SkyDiePie, PapiPie, I'm cheating on Marzia pie
DepressionPie, AustralianPie. Ok enough!
go out and find the real PewDiePie god
damn it because I don't even know if
it's me I need help
also remember to check out the G fuel
promo by the way guys 30% off give it a
try give it a try come on get at least
try out my favorite flavor "Ass"
ok guys I think it's pretty safe to say that I am
the real PewDiePie.
[Pewds2] No I am the real PewDiePie
[Pewds3] No I am the real PewDiePie